le pelage de l'année yann moix contre
les policiers
le chroniqueur de thierry ardisson est
certainement ce qu'on peut appeler un
professionnel de la polémique
cette année il a souvent été au coeur de
l'actualité mais cet échange avec des
policiers sur le plateau des terriens du
samedi sur ces huit restera sans
conteste l'une de ses sorties les plus
controversés la peur au ventre
vous n'avez pas les couilles d'aller
dans les endroits dangereux s'il n'est
pas revenu sur le fond de ses propos il
s'est tout de même excusé par la suite
de les avoir formulé de façon grossière
les vegan versus les professionnels de
la viande un combat de plus en plus
féroce d'un côté les vegan qui pour
certains d'entre eux vont jusqu'à
vandalisé des boucheries pour se faire
entendre
on se bat contre une injustice en fait
de l'autre les bouchers qui défendent
leur métier on peut faire des choses
dans le respect est correctement
sur le terrain les vegans multiplie les
actions qu'elle soit violente ou non des
actions qui exaspère de plus en plus de
bouches et booba versus caris orly une
tension entre deux artistes une
bouteille de parfum et c'est l'un des
faits divers qui a marqué notre été qui
se dessine alors que lé rappeur booba et
carris était en guerre il n'était pas
rare que les deux hommes s'insultent ou
s'humilie par réseaux sociaux interposés
et lorsque le 1er août dernier les deux
hommes et leurs équipes se rendent
compte qu'ils se retrouvent au même
moment dans le même aéroport
la rencontre est inévitable et le
résultat plutôt sanglant
les deux hommes écoperont d'une
condamnation à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis et d'une amende de 18 euros pour
enterrer la hache de guerre booba s'est
proposé d'organiser un combat de boxe
qui pourrait finalement ne pas avoir
lieu si on en croit un message posté sur
les réseaux sociaux cet après midi
alexis corbière versus eric naulleau le
député de la france insoumise alexis
corbière était invité deux balances ton
poste pour répondre aux questions des
chroniqueurs de l'émission
suite à la perquisition spectaculaire de
jean-luc mélenchon face à lui eric
naulleau et comme souvent lors d'une
rencontre entre les deux hommes le ton
est très vite monté au bout d'une minute
que j'allais zee januarie mais pas ce
qu'a fait des années que le sketch
existe non mais vous nous aimez puisqu'à
chaque fois c'est nyala delmas et un
débat c'est notre truc le sketch et ceci
même si non que je parle en général au
bout de trois 3 mois ou trois phrases
yaqub aprilia venezuela bon
[Musique]
non non ne classe que l'année vous avez
voté chez vous toute la semaine pour le
clash de l'année et le clash de l'année
ce qui a gagné alors boubakary ça arrive
en deuxième position je pensais que ce
serait beau baccharis et cv gagnent
contre professionnels de la viande qui a
gagné avec 41%
on vous fait un résumé est juste après
on aura des intervenants sur le plateau
on aura anaïs une militante vegan et on
aura gagné arthus bertrand qui sera avec
nous notamment l'un des plus grands
photo reporters français qui est très
engagé en faveur du nain divers qui sera
avec nous on aura laurent rigaud un
boucher qui est remonté je vous dis
parce qu'il a beaucoup de mal en ce
moment avec tout ce qui se passe et il y
aura un autre représentant du lundi vers
celui qui a lancé le mouvement pierre
girard regardez petit récapitulatif les
boucheries-charcuteries vandalisés
j'avais deux vitres complètement
exploser donc tu vert partout des gros
caillou à l'intérieur des images de plus
en plus courante ces derniers mois en
france ce matin le propriétaire du
magasin ne peut que constater l'ampleur
des dégâts
il ya déjà eu
une fromagerie dans le nord qui avait
été attaqué sur les vitrines toujours la
même inscription en tag antispécistes
alors première question qu'est ce que le
spécisme et le specis c'est une forme de
discrimination arbitraire basé sur
l'espèce un être humain j'ai c'est qu'il
est supérieur à un cochon ou la vache
uniquement parce qu'il est un être
humain c'est justice et deuxième
question que veulent ces militants
antispécistes le journaliste et grand
défenseur de la cause vegan aymeric
caron nous éclaire par exemple la
suppression des cages pour les poules
pondeuses a été abandonnée également
l'installation de caméras surveillant
les abattoirs car il faut dire que les
vidéos d'abattoirs qui circule sur
internet font froid dans le dos des
images insoutenables
filmé en caméra cachée dans un abattoir
pour militer contre ces pratiques
légales met en place de plus en plus
d'opérations choc les différents
bâtiments de l'abattoir sont encore
fumant après l incendie de la nuit
dernière
y'a pas de ces criminels mais aussi des
opérations pacifistes comme le lundi
vers une proposition pour l'année 2019
qui consiste à ne manger ni poisson ni
viande chaque lundi du côté des bouchers
charcutiers l'exaspération commence à se
faire sentir
on respecte leur façon de vivre alors
c'est pas c'est pas juste qu'ils nous
respectent pas notre métier on te
détruit une journée ont été détruites on
travaille quoi mais il faut qu'ils
sachent une chose c'est que je fermerai
jamais pour pour eux et vous êtes vous
d'accord avec le mouvement vegan